hello guys i'm ryan wright i'm andreas
sixthos
andreas sixtos is here today to check
out a video with me
that i um don't know what it is
but it sounds like this could be
offensive unless it's made by a black
guy
this might still be offensive the black
people song
people think andrea is black sometimes
she is not people think i'm black often
that is why
let's watch this i hope this isn't too
bad people already think i'm racist for
some reason
really you know who doesn't you know
people think i'm racist against blacks
the only subscribers that
know i'm not racist against blacks are
the black subscribers really
they're the only ones who know that i'm
just being a dumbass
i don't want to cook i haven't even had
one oh yeah yeah oh whoa
chocolate chip chocolate chip they were
fresh so they kind of smushed together
let's see what every fat guy says what
are you what are you doing to me like
it's supposed to be diet or whatever
i'll just have one just one because
it's since you made them i'm just gonna
have one let's see what the black people
song is about
this song is dedicated to a certain kind
of people
which just so happens to be
my favorite kind of people you know the
ones that
you know you're standing next to them
and it all of a sudden it gets dark
i mean i mean you know your best friend
is
you know what i'm saying right yeah
black people
i'ma steal your shoes you better hide
your wallet cause imma take that to
black people
hey
black people one big family
with a really big bucket of kfc
black people some cheap ass shots
like all of us are related i ran into an
old amigo named juan louise the mexican
called me apple cause we both hang from
trees now i
i kind of took that in the joking way
but was he talking about
monkeys of the kkk we don't get
sunburned just
as shinies and we don't chew tobacco but
we will smoke weed
puff puff pass like the train that could
and we can't spell
neighbors so we call it the hood they
tried to keep us out the white house
again but just like all white houses one
of us broke in
and well certain diapers is all we got
if you don't wear my favorite color then
you might get shot
my favorite color is purple by the way
black people
i'ma steal your shoes you better hide
your wallet cause i'ma take that to
black people
one big family with a really big bucket
of kfc
black people and it doesn't have to be
kfc we like popeye's business too
now there's a line between discriminate
and they're not in different places
you are if you use the n-word but if
you're black then you're not racist i
mean
well i guess you can just not around
your black friend you'll get jumped by
every cousin including the one behind
that trash can now
there's not really a moral to the story
though except that we will spill your
goodies
and that is how the story goes black
people imma steal your shoes
you better hide your wallet cause imma
take that to
black people people
one big family with a really big
bucket of kfc black people i hate the
fact that this is kind of catchy
black people front
this is probably the most racist song
i've ever written
but if you laugh you're racist too so i
don't feel bad
besides it's not racist if i'm black
you know i
as i was watching this i i remember
hearing about this
and people like being sort of in an
uproar about
it like it's like super duper offensive
you know yeah um now i'm gonna take a
gamble here what i'm about to say
it's all true no that's all i'm gonna
say um
what i wanted to say was i
kind of get the point of the guy's song
especially by the end
you know because he makes that point in
the middle of the song about using the
n-word
and how you know if you're black it's
not racist you know but if anyone else
has it it's racist
and i think you feel like he's making a
point about that that like regardless
it's still racist
and i feel like he's just doing satire
when he's saying he's not being racist
because i think he's very well aware
this is racist he's black too
i feel like he's going out there sort of
making a point about how you
that no matter what it's still going to
be racist right right right
that makes sense or he's just very
racist against his own people
so that's the other possible conclusion
i can come to
yeah no i think your first uh prediction
was right so who is uh
this guy who is he i've never actually
heard of him this video the black people
song has
over seven million hits z flow network
if you guys want to watch more from him
i wanna hear that chorus one more time
that [ __ ] chorus gets black people
yeah black people i'ma steal your shoes
you better hide your wallet cause i'ma
take that to
black people
hey
black people one big family
with a really big buck kfc
black people seriously like all of us
are related
wow yeah i think it's i thought it was
kind of funny in some way at first it
was like okay these are like cheap
cliche jokes
yeah but as it kept going i was like
okay i get the point of this video it
seems like it's kind of
funny actually but i like what are the
comments i want to
like i feel like these comments are
probably full of hate hate
you're just kidding to enjoy
not even a smile i know you think you're
being clever dude really
you're just giving races a new song to
enjoy that's what you said
this is racist what the [ __ ] this is the
most racist [ __ ] on the internet
mentioning the kkk and monkeys is just
way too fast
because i feel like this guy
intentionally did this video
yeah he intentionally did it just to
piss people off too
and you can tell by the response right
like
i mean you can't do the do it without
knowing that
yeah he's gonna get serious backlash so
it's funny when i read people like
getting pissed
off because i'm like he wants you to get
pissed off right so you know
you're just falling for it it's like
when i watch louie ck
he oftentimes he'll crack a joke or two
that he's just trying to get a
reaction out of the audience yeah and i
feel like he's doing that with
me and the cake like it's not funny the
kkk is a monkey's thing it's just funny
how people are responding to it because
i'm not here in like anger i was
actually asked this question today
what kind of people do you least like
and my answer
was racist and that was my honest answer
because
and i said this several times before i
don't get how one person can meet
even if they met like 20 to 30 black
people
there's no way that that 20 to 30 can
determine the millions of black people
there are
and go they're all the same right
there's it's in
it's you can't do that with any race you
can't go
oh i've met so many mexicans they're all
the same it's like that's a stupidest
statement
because there's way too many mexicans
for you to have said i've met
so many mexicans you know
there's way too many mexicans there's
way too many mexicans
there's way too many mexicans yeah so oh
man
yes so i do think racism is dumb but i
also
get a crack out of people who are out
there just to make people upset
i don't know why they just make me laugh
that's why i like eminem too
because he he just likes to make songs
to upset people
at night for some reason it cracks me up
yeah every comment here is uh really
just ripping this guy apart
yeah oh
there was one there's one people really
need to take this is a masterpiece
and damn dude is that a way to get
comment boxes [ __ ] talking to each
other you know like
if you wanna because honestly like the
best videos on youtube then sometimes i
enjoy it too
like when i see that like whoa i got a
lot more dislikes on this video than i'm
used to
i like that because then i look at the
comments and there are people who have
like two very different opinions about
something i might have said or did
and i like seeing the debate go on
because it shows you're making bold
choices
right bold old both
like the blacks bold
yeah yeah they should
they add that
blacks are bold blacks are bold they are
they are do we mean color or are they
bold as in character
and strong strong people strong yeah
but let's face it what color is it when
you bolt it listen guys
to all my black subscribers what's up my
brothers
what's up dog homies
chillin like a villain um foot show
that [ __ ] be ratchet dawg yo yo yo click
clack [ __ ]
hey guys where's overalls these days
me andreas sixthos listen guys i'm ryan
wright
i'm andrea subscribe to this
subscribe to the channel subscribe
button here somewhere
andrea sixth though so you see the
description that i put here the text
that is her instagram people follow her
there and
catch her on east los high she's the
star of the season two and three of the
show but you have to start from season
one where her sister alicia was
primarily believe in that one right she
was yeah
yeah she was like maya she played mine
jv roberts this is posted on november 6.
i get a lot of requests for shout outs
you missed my birthday shout out but
it's cool that's cool
i can wait so i have to say something
interesting well um i write
zombie post apocalyptic books for a
living you can see my entire slate of
books as well as my blog
at jvroberts.com uh jvroberts.com
is oh there it is whoa dude that's
pretty cool
whoa that's like real [ __ ]
oh my god he's seriously legit
look at that you can buy these from
amazon too
no kidding it's got four stars four
stars out of 46 people
what way to go man who are you and why
are you watching this channel
no making a living making me laugh
you sound like an intellectual guy who's
like writing his novels and stuff
and we're like i'm gonna go watch the
real rejects right now
why um happy birthday to you by the way
jv
that's like a serious compliment to you
i think yeah if he watches your show
you know what jv stands for right jewish
vaginas
oh i see
jewish vaginas i never knew that ryan
i've made a lot of like sex jokes
never gotten the response the noise that
you just made
which just made me not want to do the
whole bit um
let's take care jewish vagina take care
take care
mr roberts